both presidential campaigns are
targeting nevada they hope to put the
silver state in their column on election
night
hector mejia live this morning at an
early voting site in the southwest
valley with a look at this week's events
hector good morning
hey there john good morning and yeah
it's the last week to vote earlier
around the valley at more than 35
sites and that's the reason why we're
here this is one of those early voting
sites
this is in the southwest and we are
expecting to see voters in long lines
before this place even opens
at nine o'clock this morning we're at a
shopping center by rainbow and the 215
and we're down to the final week before
election day
both presidential campaigns are in high
gear here in our state
president donald trump will be in
bullhead city later this week
frey make america great again victory
rally that's set for noon on wednesday
his son eric trump is hosting events in
reno and las vegas tomorrow
senator kamala harris is also making her
pitch tomorrow in reno in las vegas
and over the weekend superstar cher was
in town campaigning for joe biden
part of her message to voters get out
and vote now
i've known joe since 2006
and i and this is what i think that's
something really important and that is
you cannot build
anything unless you build it on the
truth
and i believe that that's one of joe's
great
great attributes
cher is throwing her full support behind
joe biden and kamala harris
she along with congresswoman susie lee
addressed more than 100 people at that
event and remember
your vote does matter registered voters
can go to any early voting site around
the county
no matter where it's located reporting
live hector mejia
8 news now